what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today and or finale time joined of
course
John Hi how are you all right give me a
second oh good I'm feeling rebellious
I'm ready for a finale how are you doing
oh John yeah leave a like people
Everyone leave a like please go ahead
and do that use the force to subscribe
and click that notification Bell to get
notified when we got a reaction up here
on this channel that might be of your
interest and as always and I want to say
a special thank you to all who have
joined our patreon page you guys have
been saviors in our lives so thank you
very much full-length stretch watch
along as we sync up with your own copy
for Andor available for super sexy
rejects along with a bunch of other
shows that we covered exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included over there all right ladies and
gentlemen
May the force be with you
gorgeous as always
that lens flare just there was a tribute
to JJ Abrams Easter egg
like a Deidra coming into her own
wow the dark side Looms on pharynx today
who's that hologram of
is that Andrews I guess so it must be
maybe he's trying to like alter it or
something I spoke to Cassian what he
called the shop ow picked up the old box
line and there he was and I said his
name a hundred times he asked about
funerals nice walk
spies everywhere
building some kind of weapon it's like a
bomb
I'd be losing my mind
one another
just one there's a trap get him drunk
enough to talk why worry it though it's
not like he knows about it I guarantee
you he's got no idea what's going on
Bank on that don't be so sure
dude you know something I don't
do me a favor keep it that way
oh you're clever
you're gambling again
nonsense and here in Coruscant that's
ridiculous
do you have any idea how tired of this I
am
it's alive
you can't live without a casino fine
you go to Kanto bikes
I feel like she was gonna name drop it
best subplot
I was on my way to pick you up this guy
I've been watching his ISB he's a guy in
town his boss showed up tonight
good to see you too the mission comes
first
he returns
not even wearing his hood
I really wish he grew that beard back
stand back let it drip look how quickly
that's cleaned up 500 credits each
people
don't look down the way they should
and I look down I don't look past the
Russ trash and treasure
interesting
so is it a metaphor that he's that thing
yeah
it just needs to take a dunk
what are you doing here just keeping an
eye on the place till we sell it
where is she
oh God
where is she oh no no no no that that's
the final thrust of fighting in this
Rebellion tyridine requires constant
effort it breaks it leaks
Authority is brittle oppression is the
mask of fear
remember that I oppression is the mask
of fear it will come when all these
skirmishes and battles
these moments of defiance will have
flooded the banks of the Empire's
Authority and then there will be one too
many one single thing will break The
Siege pharynx Will Rise
um for this to go down at his mom's
funeral how fitting the control position
is here here and here will have snipers
in a containment unit there containment
yes snipers know I want him taken alive
I want that message passed along the
line
clearly
you should pass that message along
yourself
this episode is spies and paranoia mon
mothma is of great interest here having
her husband dig a hole for himself
could be helpful in many ways it sounded
like Perrin had done this before
they've made some odd banking
you can close out your Anto Krieger
files
how many attacks still counting the
bodies
walked right into it it was ever before
they started
wow
that hood is gonna blow right back down
I hope Nico finds his way here just
swims to ferricks
I learned to swim
off camera
foreign
oh what a tight hug I told her I was
coming back stop I never should have
left that morning stop
he told me you'd say all this
tell him none of this is his fault
it was already burning he's just the
first Spark of the fire
I when the day comes those two pull
together he will be an Unstoppable Force
for good
oh wow
I love him more than anything he could
ever do wrong
oh
take that love into the feet of that
door
Where it All Began morlano one that's
weird I'll be in actually yeah
[Music]
Somewhere Out There Star Wars theories
falling asleep
he almost hear him snoring now
I don't want to go live gotta find him
we'll kill him
where will they take him the hotel
that's our Target
you just need him dead before they start
asking questions
interesting
nah I'm trying to hold back from
telegraphing right now and I have a
feeling I know what's going to go down
I like how there's barely any music it
really puts you in the midst of
everything
[Music]
[Music]
it's like serving as a funeral March and
as a prepare for battle March not too
different when you think about it
away get these people off the streets
man this is so cold they're just trying
to mourn surrounded by the bricks of the
Dead
[Music]
recognizes walk yeah
double the reward you found it I want
twice as much and a ride out of him when
it's over where is he pretend you're
arrested me
got it they're ready they just want to
pop off any way they can
I need him alive Don't make me say it
again
oh
poor B you charged up enough to mourn
[Music]
ah
it's like mirroring uh andor's flashback
foreign
[Music]
from work
oh wow that's great
the music's all coming from in show yeah
that's awesome all diegetic
oh brilliant what are you gonna reverse
all of us yeah brilliant oh
ferrick's Rising
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] some [ __ ] spots go down
[Music]
I love the way they do the cultures
my name is
happening I was always eager always
waiting to be inspired the Dead
Lifted Me
with their truth
oh you have a change of heart there man
did
and I earned to lift you
I want ferricks to continue
in my waning hours
that's what comforts me most
but I fear for you oh these above head
shots man climb we took their money and
ignored them we kept their engines
churning and the moment they pulled away
we forgot them
because we had each other
great speech we were sleeping and I've
been turning away from the truth I
wanted not to face
there is a wound that won't heal at the
center of the Galaxy
there is a Darkness reaching like rust
into everything to everything around us
we let it grow and now it's here
the Empire is a disease that thrives in
darkness it is a never More Alive than
when we sleep holy [ __ ]
[Music]
it's easy for the dead to tell you to
fight and maybe it's true maybe fighting
is useless
rise up today perhaps it's too late
I'll tell you this
[Music]
if I could do it again
I'd wake up early
fighting yes yes
all right
fight the Empire
oh you son of a [ __ ]
kill him bring me his head
oh
riot
[Applause]
fight back Rebel
nicely done
[Applause]
coward crawl buddy coward
do not shoot the Anvil man I gotta get
out of here
I've always here
it wasn't she great
come on dude make some damage back there
[Applause]
yep it's time dudes come on do it
yes
land her right on top of it
oh
[Music]
whoa ow I thought Cyril's gonna take
that yeah
combo
wow
that must have killed everybody
hey so much for taking the emperor's
mind off about Donny look at this
fight Santa did not prepare for oh my
God the rebellion's here
yeah come on let's crack some helmets oh
he had buttered the helmet and he went
down
got them hard skulls on ferrets
thank you
oh my God
pull that helmet off
Stormtrooper can aim
no
[Music]
oh no
oh good
squat
what are you doing here
oh
[Music]
shazbot man that felt personal yeah
get me out of there protect me at all
costs
[Music]
wow
oh my god oh
dang armor plated hat appreciate that
for capturing this in such like a ugly
way it is the benefit of not
of like laser blasters not being bloody
as you can just see how nasty this all
is
[Music]
that dude climbed that Tower forever for
nothing
Terror apart
oh my oh my God
right now
oh they got themselves a hostage oh
Cyril that's Cyril is that Cyril that's
Cyril
kiss her you fool come on
I love you oh my god kiss you freaks you
Natural Born Killers you and they're
gonna go all the way in that closet
right now damn Andrew's barely even in
the fight
so frustrated
what about this everything goes pause it
empty
bleeding it's fine
it's blood not hurt it's not mine
ultimate badass line
give me those
don't go you go now we'll forget it
kiss him you fool
oh
[Music]
Jeremy Cassian come on
it's your only family left can they make
it to ganji Moon if they ever make it
out of here
you're not coming
stay low all the way too far side sea
the moment you get over the water you
climb
and turtle no cons
Ole
you understand yeah
you're not coming no no I never got to
see you oh
I'm counting on you
you always say that
and you always come through get them out
of here
you'll find
that I'll find you
now go go go
fly you fools
time for a wedding
God the mom's the Bride of Frankenstein
make him a bride
okay what game is this
no game
kill me
or take me in
[Music]
but I won 50 000 credits
you promised from before I gave back to
Crystal
well done well done teams mcgeebs they
did good that episode didn't they what
spots I know
so they do good buddy
[Laughter]
nice
oh my goodness
all that hard work
oh
wow that's so cool
[Music]
that is an image yeah
foreign
are you building parts for the Death
Star but you're building parts for the
most lethal part of the test yeah the
most what life erasing part of the Death
Star crazy crazy stuff that should cry
let's talk about it you mother F words
all right that was a wonderful
culmination episode everything came
together in the end
it did it all worked out it all worked
out everything turned out remember the
beat's going to be here everybody wins
no I loved uh marva's speech
um
given her own eulogy that was great A
Goodbye message kind of reminds you of
like when
my first thought was actually
um oh my God who did uh
would Jim Carrey play a man on the moon
oh Andy Coffee I have any coffin
um oh of yeah like prepping something in
advance I mean many people do that and I
thought it was great that you know like
it was such a bummer that she stayed
behind in a big part of her reason to
stay behind was to
give Fuel and provide help and be a part
of the rebellion in some way because she
could feel that there was a rise
happening but her her death and the
Gathering and Her speech was the
linchpin to it all yeah and I thought
that was so beautiful that this all got
to go down at her funeral like there's
no other way she would have wanted this
funeral to go down and granted did she
want her some her own people to die from
Ferris not no However the fact that the
Rebellion did
for the ferrics like this this was such
a Monumental moment and watching this
rise happen and
um you know one thing I remember when I
first walked out of Rogue one and I
think we shared the same sentiment here
was that
that movie kind of put the war in Star
Wars and this really did that into an
even more Grim effect because you know
you're like good let's go let's go but
it never turned into badassery the way
you think it might turn into yeah it
stayed very bleak
and just so so sad the entire time it
felt like you see the ugly side of War
here or even in Star Wars a lot of the
time it is like rousing and spectacle
and whatnot yeah and never never turned
into that it it remained that this felt
like a real brutality and uh like a real
war zone basically is what I'm getting
at it's about like actually seeing blood
so yeah but it the way that the images
they chose to to capture would like the
police holding the front line and the
bashing the people with their uh batons
you know and opening fire into the crowd
yeah yeah it was really ugly and like
thematically I just thought everything
tied in and plot wise everything you
know
unfolded together too with all the
characters coming together at this one
meeting point and I do feel like it is a
completion of a season one as because
yeah it ends on a cliffhanger and not
that I feel like the story would end
here but I feel like the specific
chapter they decided to tell because
we've gone in you know like every three
to four episodes it was kind of telling
a new chapter of the season and then
here they brought it all around where it
sort of felt like part one of a novel
sure you know or like the first the
first novel in a series of novels yeah
yeah and and I thought they did an
excellent just Exquisite job but
you know bring up something different
yeah no two things this was this was so
so rich and and yeah I thought that they
it's like Rogue one
it is really well proportioned as a
movie because it is like the story of
one particular battle and this great
fodder for a war movie whereas this is
yeah honing in on there are battles
there is the actual fight but so much of
what war is is the strategizing and the
build up and the really harsh decisions
and the weird things that you have to
live with in the ways in which you have
to cross your own moral boundaries and
yeah this was very
this was rousing but in a completely uh
different kind of way because yeah you
do associate I associate you know Star
Wars with a certain amount of hope uh
and then and not to say that there isn't
hope but it's it's showing you just how
much you have to put into hope like I
feel like people look at Hope as this
external force that lifts you up but you
have to fill that well and you're
watching you know over the course of
this season as Cassie and Andor commits
to going to that well and and nurturing
that well and I thought it was really
beautifully handled the way they brought
everybody that seems so disparate and
and and that was never really
telegraphed this way but they brought
everybody here and you see how everybody
is and isn't mostly isn't prepared for
this and I thought that was a really
cool thing because we've watched so like
over the season all these machinations
all these plans being built and
especially through characters like
Deidra and Luth and you see the two
sides that are very assured of their
hand and even though there are variables
you see the the prowess of strategy and
here everything comes together in a
complete mess for everybody which I
think is especially striking but it puts
the hands back into the it puts the
power or at least the momentum the
moment back into just the people's hands
like I love that as much as you have all
of our main figures of The Ensemble
throughout this episode and you have
that tension of their proximity and kind
of what each of them what role they're
playing so much of what really is
impactful about this episode is just
what the people of pharynx as led by
Marva choose to do and then we zoom into
these little personal moments in between
that but I think especially for again a
Star Wars series honing in on the idea
of War I think that's a really beautiful
thing because it does kind of show it in
a stark sense and I think it's the first
time I've ever watched something like
this and thought to myself you know what
I'm happy that there isn't blood with
these blasters because for what this is
we can level up and we can use the fact
that you can get pretty gritty and
pretty harsh and pretty you know uh
realistic to a degree with violence you
know if you do not have the blood and so
here I thought that plays to a really
great great effect a really harsh effect
but an effect that really grabs you and
it's like this I'm sure it's happened
before but this is the first time I can
remember where like the the culmination
of the the
just the all the pent-up emotion that
boils over at the start of a battle
really hit me in this episode so you're
watching them process through the street
when it became clear that the funeral
procession was also about to become a
full-on fight a full-on like rebellious
act in the moment like that really moved
me like this is a really moving episode
in a way that I didn't ever really
expect but I'm I'm just as the best of
Star Wars can give you that like whoop
your fist and like yes you know that
catharsis this was a wholly different
catharsis but you know a part of that
same picture of hope you know just in
again the harsher more formative stages
of what that hope can do and be and the
fact that you have to you know shine
that light so intentionally through the
dark
um but yeah this is this was
I mean I feel like this is gonna sit
with me and sort of process through my
system for the next several days but I
was really wowed by this and as a
culmination of the season I just hats
off so much of the discourse about Star
Wars is about like who had a plan and
what that plan amounted to and this
series feels like the product of
excellent planning and an excellent grip
on themes first and foremost yeah and I
like that uh they had this
attention to detail with luthin and Val
and all of them as being the center
point for where the Rebellion really
sprung up and it did you know without
Donnie being the a major moving point so
turning that needle even for Marva like
if that didn't happen Marvel wouldn't
have been moved to do what she to stay
would ferricks and perhaps even give
that speech you know
and I I like that
you they show up and it's like they
don't they're not even prepared for for
this yeah you know and yet you have
of course I'm blinking on the name now
the book
the one who left behind everything for
Android
yeah like you even bring that back
around and you see that he that and or
has been absorbing all of that because
you know he is that character in this
series where him being such a
centerpiece for it all and like
everyone's here just preparing for we're
looking for Android we got to get Andrew
we gotta kill land or yeah you know
that's what it's all coming down to and
yet they're they're so focused on that
they're they've kind of turned a blind
eye to the fact that oh wait we got all
these other people here that are
actually feeling a lot of hostility and
really not handling the oppression you
know like they're ready to throw down
and I like that Lutheran and Velo
they're not even prepared for that yeah
when this is such a big cause for why
they exist and what they're fighting for
and this all stems within the the family
of Andor you know and I like how Cassian
through his journey being that art type
character who you know you can tell that
obviously we know you know from catching
up with him in Rogue one or whatnot that
he's gonna be that guy who is like so
resistant towards resistance who's so
resistant toward the rebellion and and
doesn't believe in it but through all
the cards that keep being dealt his way
he's moved through to joining the
rebellion in the end of course bringing
it back full circle from that fourth
episode when he is on the ship with
luthin and Lutheran is trying to
convince him into fighting for it and
with I forgot his name again what the
hell
um
I call him Ecom oh man like I know
that's on it uh with nemec and there's
always and in Marvel too you know always
trying to instill the willingness to
fight back and fight for this cause
and it's taken a lot of sacrifice and a
lot of personal movement and experiences
for him to get to that point that didn't
feel cliche in how we got there it
wasn't just like
marva's Dead all right I'm I'm now
feeling it because she died and I got to
do this for her did it turn into that
which is what I thought they were gonna
do and it it didn't go down that path I
mean sure it's a part of it I imagine
with this character but so much his
performance is so internal but you can
pick up on it just from the littlest
bits of details even from him going into
the prison uh and and seeing just wow
these guys are not messing around you
know they they don't even give you a
second chance at life at any capacity so
I I love the way how we got and or to
the closing point of I'm going to fight
now not for money not for monetary and
not to escape and not not for just pure
selfish reasons or anything like that it
is because he has found a reason to
fight in this rebellion and it's
something that he now believes in so
they've they brought that all around
with the characters too like I love the
little look of exchanges that already
has with Lutheran at the end this whole
time wants to kill him but he can like
that smile he gives that little yeah
absolutely a little tiny smirk of Hope
like he's coming he's coming he's come
around this sandor he's coming around
he's part of it now
um I love that I think I think that was
really great I think some things I could
have used a little bit more flushing out
for me are Val and cinta Santa I mean
sinto
feels like a is like an important
character but I'm gonna use a little bit
more detail with her and and getting to
know who she really is it's just a
little bit better and there are some
people on pharynx who I'm like I really
like them when they're there but I I
wish I I got to know them a little bit
better to to care a tad bit more about
them you know yeah who we have checked
in with periodically
um so yeah there are some things there
that I feel like can be
um explored a little bit more come the
next season
and
yeah so we didn't really get a good a
solid like we really just got like a
cliffhanger with mon mothma we didn't
really get a chapter closed so much
other than you know with her getting the
money and handing off their kid yeah
yeah like that's a good Cliffhanger but
I I felt like we could use a more of a
chapter of clothes for that yeah I like
how hers ends on such a dark note you
know like everyone else's kind of ends
on a semi hopeful note if you're one of
the good guys one of the protagonists
but hers is just so so Bleak oh yeah
it's like everybody is everybody on the
ground is stepping out of the shadows
and now she has to step further into the
Shadows yeah it's all aimed toward the
same goal but yeah how much how much
more harsh in the moment in in a way
personally at least that that seems yeah
so I actually I do like where it ended
with her I'm not saying I don't I don't
like it I do like where it ended with
her because of that contrast it just
feels like a step rather than like a
whole Arc yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um but you've been watching or descend
through this whole season and
I do like how just uh unprepared the
empire was for what came their way in
this episode too yeah which felt like a
realistic way of depicting it into a
certain extent because
they are just so they underestimate and
they're so focused and you know they did
bring it back with
um Krieger dying and
even with the ISB officer saying you
know like this this was about
I forget what exactly would this exact
sentence was but you know it was this it
was to send the statement and to and to
wipe it clean which is what Lutheran
wanted was for them to feel like they
have ultimate power over this like oh
they just walked right into this and it
was easy peasy so now the emperor's
happy yeah the emperor's happy and
because of an incident like that it
probably made it easier for what
happened at Ferris for them to fight
back too just like that little bit of an
uh give enough to underestimate that can
give more power so I I thought that was
great and like Deidre and Cyril even
coming together
you know I want Twisted ass Duo here but
I I like them together I do they're
creepy as hell together I like them
there's a bunch of freaks those two yes
I'm very excited to see who they become
in season two they're gonna have a very
kinky relationship moving forward I can
I can already tell yeah
yeah yeah that was great
um and the use of music too like you
pointed out that there's so much just
Foley and so much just
um you know natural sound and then they
have these extended patches like there's
a little bit of score music because I
started to pay attention but I love that
yeah you have so much that's just sound
effects of the environment and then you
have this long extended sequence of
Music where the music itself is sort of
the main character and everybody else is
focused in on that and it's completely
motivated by what's on screen like
there's so many really Lively creative
choices throughout all this too like as
as great as like the storytelling and
the writing and all that stuff is like
it's also really beautifully realized
and and you know is one of the most
immersive Star Wars shows I feel like
we've had in a way as much as I loved
galavanting about the Galaxy and there
are things I love about you know each of
the series this one feels the most like
you're just there yeah yeah well it
sucks you into it's mood and that
atmosphere this episode in particular
because of its Choice with its more
longer lasting shots and with
um the one to when to use music when not
to use music and then a big portion when
you got the music was just from the
procession you know like that letting
that drive the mood more
oh that was great too that b it was the
one to
um project the Hologram yeah and then
what a half-assed attempt that one guy
to cover it up that is big guys coat I
don't know like if you didn't do that
man they might not have fought back
there might have been still some
hesitation one is great because they
don't wink at you and they don't go haha
he was right about uh you know the
Empire back in the you know in the
prison you know and and you know you can
see how I I loved that basically that
you have the whole Krieger thing play
out in the background almost the entire
time and I love that even the guy here
is like you guys are you using hear
about this creatures like I feel like
it's been a detail it's been kind of
hard for people to keep track of but I
love that you have that and then you
kind of come back around to a situation
you watch so many people even on a low
scale like the guy uh um the two guys
who tip off the uh Imperials that
andor's here and get them looking for
him you know the guys who betray them
like you watch so many people agree to
letting circumstances happen just so
that they're and your opponent won't be
any the wiser and then you end up in a
situation where both sides are not the
wiser about what's about to happen and
so yeah it's it also kind of
gives a good kind of call to both sides
that you got to really be paying
attention oh most definitely yeah most
definitely yeah and even with Bix like
where you're talking about with with
hope I think the one person who and or
directly gives hope to
is mix you know she's someone who is
completely hopeless at this point and
doesn't even know she's physically all
there like she has a lot to regain
physically and mentally yeah you know uh
after the torture she endured so
that moment at the very end where they
all felt like there's hope within Andor
yeah when they are getting away I
thought was
really powerful and really elevated the
Android character himself yeah so yeah
there's I think there's a lot of Beauty
on display in this episode and I think
it was just fleshed out really well with
uh
with
uh with the more human side of the war
in Star Wars I would say like
even the after effects that you see when
when the wars when the battle's done and
you're cutting around and seeing some
people who are just drained and tired
and emotionally distraught
I appreciate that that like like I said
it's it there's more of it like an
adventurous Spirit usually within the
battles of Star Wars and you don't
really get this side where you just see
people are torn apart and uh it makes
you I made me appreciate it and so yeah
I think you really capture the human
side and I feel like that's kind of the
point of this this series is to show you
the The Human Side of the rebellious
spirit and that usually starts with
hopelessness so yeah well and two so
much of I guess the last thing is I feel
like so much of again Star Wars has
these really iconic heroic characters
and one thing I appreciated about Rogue
one that I think they've also carried
over in a beautiful way here is the way
in which a a person who maybe played a
brief role can be so important it's like
nemec hasn't been around for a while and
yet he feels like a real presence in
this episode and like a crucial presence
and even having Andor the complaint many
people have of like Android even really
seem like the fully main character I
feel like that even still goes to kind
of bolster that overall theme of like
you do see where his Arc and his journey
and why he is at the center of all this
but also you see the contribution of so
many other smaller players who might not
be you know hoisted to the level that a
Luke Skywalker kind of character would
be or anything well it's not like the
show seems disinterested in Andor and
nor does it seem like they're forcing
Andor to be the star yeah you know uh I
think that they they could have put
themselves in a position where it felt
that way or like literally they're not
that interested in writing Android
version everyone else yeah uh but they I
think they naturally make and or the
center of the show and I think he does a
great job I think Diego Luna is a really
like an excellent job it's like yeah the
other characters are more exciting and
and uh they're fresh they're new and
they're sometimes we're just given more
to do in in acting wise and plot wise
you know so sometimes you do give them
more stuff uh but Andor is the main
moving puzzle to all this yeah you know
uh he's not exactly like Mad Max kind of
you know yeah you watch him go from Mad
Max to the you know yeah I mean kind of
to if he really if Mad Max really found
a cause that he wanted to stick with for
the rest of his life yeah you know
instead of moving on to the next one
yeah yeah and I do think uh the post
credit scene was fun
um yeah tying it back to the desk I mean
I thought it was I think a lot of us
might have thought that right they were
building [ __ ] for the Death Star I was
just more like a timeline of this right
because they that they get
um or so Galen uh to start building it
uh when did that start like okay Jin was
a child are they like the same in age
her and Andor so that would make sense
if they're already starting development
on it yeah yeah yeah that's far that far
along especially yeah yeah because it
took him a very long time to build that
thing so yeah when did they break ground
of the Death Star
to put that together so you know and I
think like maybe next season is when you
do see krennic or you do see Galen
um and you probably get k2so like that's
where you get the Rogue one characters
who come in yeah get melshi back yeah I
think you'll get I think you start to
get more of these other characters here
which is fun yeah and then we could
finally get Andor and mon mothma meeting
each other
if Bob Iger agrees the green light let's
keep season two AJ just started shooting
today did they apparently we gotta start
shooting him
our numbers haven't been the best quick
screaming is already
start shooting before he says no start
shooting we're gonna be shooting till
next summer I don't know we already
started shut us down now it cost you
more money yeah that's not a don't be a
don't be a Warner Brother just air it
don't don't tax write off us yeah
alrighty well
um yeah this is a slam dunk I thought
every episode was great uh it wasn't a
weak episode of me I mean some are more
exciting than others but uh in terms of
was there a week episode no this was uh
very a wildly consistent show in my
opinion I know there's a big part of the
fan base
it didn't rely on the old streaming show
just make the opening and the ending
good and whatever's in the middle is up
to the fans yeah no yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it wasn't just about getting you to
watch the next episode and it felt like
the appropriate length too which is
almost shocking these days and I feel
like you know as much as I like the week
to week I feel like it'd be a good binge
sure yeah yeah it's it's it's just a
well unified piece yeah for sure for
sure all right guys what did you think
about the Andor finale of the show hit
the landing for you leave your thoughts
down below
it's kind of crazy how like book of Boba
Fett ended
in a city with the people fighting back
and stuff and and they did this too
in the hometown Turf but just so much
more interesting this feels he has so
much more real yeah it's like a fun
house all right guys that's nice for the
patreon
Gabriel Gabrielle ah beat me to it our
Guardian Angel here yeah you've been a
patron of ours for six months and I want
to say thank you for being part of our
page for these last six months I hope to
see you for another six months uh please
know that your support has been not
overlooked it has been very much
instrumental in our lives so thank you
for
thank you for being you and for being as
generous as you are and for not asking
much from us despite giving so much to
us uh that's the kind of people we are
we like to receive not the biggest fan
of giving to take so you know I think
it's a fair relationship and I think
you've found the right ground with us
here so thank you Gabriel for the right
people to enable I hope you have uh I
hope we have a great holiday season I
hope you have a great Thanksgiving and I
just wanted to say thank you so much
Gabrielle for uh being here and
look at any information your orders this
oh is that is that Quebec are you in
Quebec are you quebecois
and being the great white North living
up in America's hat what is that Quebec
yeah up in Canada
[Music]
nice to know you no wonder you're so
nice yeah we we you're a quebecian yeah
well thank you so much and uh I hope
that you have a great rest of your
Thanksgiving my friend
Mel C and uh I will not okay
hey everybody thank you
[Music]